when you think of electricity what's the
first thing that comes to mind
probably a wire we're used to thinking
of metals is the best way to conduct
electric current and it's true metals
are found in pretty much all the
electronics that we use in lightbulbs
phones computers TVs and countless other
appliances but believe it or not there
are certain non metals such as
conductive plastics that can act as
conductors to their special properties
challenge our assumptions about
nonmetals and allow them to harness the
power of electricity
although electricity can seem like magic
the science behind it is pretty simple
an electric current is just the flow of
electrons from atom to atom different
types of atoms are better at conducting
electrons than others which is why
materials like metals are generally more
conductive than others this is because
the electrons of metals are delocalized
meaning that the outermost electrons in
a metal atom are held loosely allowing
them to flow more freely in contrast the
outer electrons in the atoms of a
nonmetal
are held more closely to the nucleus
preventing movement think about an
electrical wire inside the charges flow
easily through the metal filaments on
the outside the rubber coating keeps
these charges from flowing into our
bodies and electrocuting us when we
touch the wire but electrically
conductive plastics turn this idea on
its head these plastics are polymers
long chains made of smaller repeating
units known as monomers by changing the
structure of the atoms within the
monomers these plastics can actually
become just as conductive as certain
metals it sounds pretty cool right you
might think that some brilliant chemist
made these plastics specifically for
this purpose but like so many other
important discoveries in science this
one was an accident it happened in the
lab of Hideki shirokawa when the
chemical compound polyacetylene was
mixed incorrectly normally black and
powdery the comp out instead formed a
silvery film that looked distinctly
metallic wondering if this strange
substance would exhibit metallic
properties Shirakawa shared the
discovery with chemist allan mcdermid
and physicist allan heger after
experimenting with many different
processes they just
covered that they could actually
increase the conductivity of
polyacetylene derive about of certain
metals with the addition of bromine gas
for instance the conductivity of
polyacetylene increased ten million fold
to a level that approached that of
copper although a different conductive
polymer polyaniline had existed for
almost two centuries the accidental
discovery of polyacetylene brought the
field of conductive polymers to the
forefront and opened up revolutionary
new possibilities for experimentation
while metals are generally the best
conductors we have available today there
are many downsides to their use mining
shipping and processing metals is
expensive conductive polymers are
attractive alternatives because they are
lightweight cheap and functionally
versatile so how did these conductive
polymers were like in metals the flow of
electric charge in conductive polymers
is generated by voltage a difference in
the electrical potential of the negative
and positive poles of a battery or an
outlet the negatively charged electrons
are drawn towards the positive pole and
they create a current as they pass from
atom to atom but like we mentioned the
electrons of polymers usually aren't too
localized and cannot easily move around
to conduct current but let's take
another look at polyacetylene if you
look closely you'll notice that there's
an alternating pattern of single and
double bonds holding the atoms of the
polymer together this is known as a
conjugated backbone along this backbone
the Sigma bonds hold each atom together
by concentrating electrons directly
between them the PI bonds which
constitute the second bond in each
double bond strengthen the connection
between their atoms by attracting
electrons above and below the plane of
the molecule
this forms delocalized orbitals where
the mobility of electrons can be
enhanced through a process called doping
this process essentially changes the
number of electrons in the polymer by
either removing or adding electrons to
the atom removing electrons creates
empty spaces and the outermost orbital
of the atom allowing the remaining
electrons to move around more freely
adding electrons forces an atom to
create another orbital and so long as
this orbital isn't full the electrons
have more space to move around and hop
from atom to atom you can think of it
like a pool table full of billiard balls
the balls would be able to move around
if they weren't getting in each other's
way
but if you take out a few balls the rest
of them can move around or alternately
if you add more balls you need to add a
new pool table in this new pool table
they have lots of room to move around
the more easily they can move around the
more easily they can transport charges
and conduct electrical currents although
initially no one believed that polymers
could conduct electricity the scientific
community has since caught up to
Shirakawa research in 2000 shirokawa
MacDermid and heger were awarded the
Nobel Prize in Chemistry and the
researcher and conductive polymers has
grown exponentially ever since while the
full potential of conductive polymers
has yet to be discovered
there are countless possibilities for
developments in technology and medical
science such as high-capacity batteries
artificial muscles and biosensors so
while we probably won't see plastics
entirely replacing metals in our
lifetime the field of conductive
polymers has huge potential especially
for something that began as a mistake